[Music]
okay I'm gonna need to stop you right
there
the year is 1994 and Double Dragon is
the second video game movie ever
released one year after the masterpiece
we all know as Super Mario Brothers
brothers since the early nineties
moviegoers have been played by the
epidemic of bad video game movies most
recently with Tomb Raider which now
joins a long list of absolutely
god-awful cash grabs don't be too
careful these days the world has gone
bloody mad but this video isn't about
what makes a bad video game movie that
subject has been done to death rather I
want to focus on the things these giant
multi-billion dollar companies can do to
make their movies better primarily stop
treating the movie like it's a video
game okay so what do I mean by that well
video games and movies are two
completely different mediums and as such
they need to be treated differently in
terms of how they tell a story as
Nintendo's Shigeru Miyamoto told Fortune
magazine because games and movies seem
like similar mediums people's natural
expectation is we want to take our games
and turn them into movies
I've always felt video games being an
interactive medium and movies being a
passive medium mean the two are quite
different there are countless examples
of video game companies dictating how
their stories should be told
meddling in the writing process and
turning the finished product into some
Frankenstein version of memorable
characters and plot lines from the game
these companies & executives dictating
how a story and a completely different
medium should be told is like having a
carpenter tell a sculptor how to do
their job you guys seen it yet
would you recommend to your friends that
they go see it but we mustn't lose sight
of the fact that making a good movie is
hard enough as it is let alone one that
is adapted from a video game in fact
it's estimated that half of Hollywood
movies don't even make a profit so if
video games and movies are 2 different
mediums how do you transfer characters
plot and ideas from one to the other
without it being a shitty mess the
answer lies in Sid fields book
screenplay in his chapter on adaptation
field points out that the way to
approach adaptation is to treat your
source material as malleable you can
take change add subtract anything to
make it fit into the structure of film
sounds easy right
not really you see when you don't open
yourself up to the possibility of these
changes you get movies where they try to
cram in as many characters as possible
even though they don't help the story at
all well it still feels pretty wrong to
me not to mention that what passes for a
storyline in a videogame doesn't
necessarily mean it will work in film in
most video games story isn't the driving
force gameplay is and weaker stories can
be overlooked if the gameplay is
phenomenal
essentially what field is getting at
here is that the source material needs
to be molded into the structure of film
for him that would be the traditional
three act structure a structure that
allows videogame stories some of which
can take in excess of 60 hours to
complete to fit into the standard
hour-and-a-half runtime of most films in
fact many video games already follow
this structure take for example the
Legend of Zelda Ocarina of Time it can
fit nicely into the three-act structure
act 1 young link act 2 adult link saves
the sages act 3 the final battle with
Ganondorf of course this would require
massive changes primarily revamping the
story to make it less generic and
implementing many cuts cutting
characters people love and changing plot
lines can be a huge risk for the holders
of these properties but it's something
that needs to be done part of what made
the Lord of the Rings so successful was
its ability to depart from the book
character favorites like Tom Bombadil
were cut completely scenes like the
death of Boromir which appears in the
Fellowship movie actually take place in
two towers the book they were rearranged
so they'd flow better in the visual
medium of film as field writes the hub
of adaptation is fine
balance between the characters and the
situation yet keeping the integrity of
the story so what steps can big
companies like Nintendo Blizzard or
Ubisoft do to ensure they make quality
films not just disingenuous cash grabs
first they need to understand that film
and video games are two completely
different mediums and as such recognize
that what makes something great in a
video game doesn't necessarily mean it
will be great in the film you can get up
now
and check your diaper second and this is
hugely important is that story is more
important than fanservice I'm just so
excited to see the world of Azeroth
brought to such a vivid light and a
Technicolor tapestry of regal magentas
in other world degrees this might mean
you have to cut characters change the
plot around or come up with completely
different stories altogether but that
too many of these big companies and
studios is a giant risk and until these
companies grow some balls I fear we'll
continue to get generic cut and paste
video game stories which simply try to
replicate action scenes found in the
game don't get me wrong as much as I
[ __ ] about video game movies I want
nothing more than to see amazing video
game stories and characters on the big
screen but until we start treating video
games is something more than nostalgia
we're in for a whole lot of the same
[Music]
hey if you liked this video make sure to
subscribe and check out my other content
below
[Music]